bien bonjour à tous et merci de nous
donner l'opportunité de présenter ce
pour quoi j'ai orienté ma carrière
désormais depuis quinzaine d'années et
sur lequel vous allez voir j'y crois et
mon objectif aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas
vous laisser indifférent
une révolution de quoi qu'il en soit on
doit la passé donc je vais essayer
aujourd'hui de vous expliquer d'où elle
vient
pourquoi elle est là ensuite poser les
bases pour que vous la comprenez que
vous voyez comment il va vous impactés
et puis après vous faire réfléchir et on
en discutera la fin alors la première
phase vous demande pas de tout lire
mais c'est poser des bases à la télé vos
enfants tout ce qu'on vous dit vous
parle d'impression 3d et bien
l'impression 3d c'est une et
technologies de la fabrication additive
et la fabrication additive c'est ce
qu'on va opposer à la fabrication
soustractive c'est à dire que tout ce
que veut l'industrie de partir dans
cubes de matière et d'enlever de la
matière pour arriver à la forme finale
de la pièce l'objectif de la fabrication
additive c'est plutôt de partir de
poudre ou de fils et de joindre la
matière l'une à l'autre
le lego mais à l'échelle de la poudre
alors on va essayer de voir d'où cette
voie parce que c'est là le plus
important sur ce graphe vous avez deux
axes importants
le premier c'est la variété des produits
et le deuxième c'est la quantité de
produit alors au 19e siècle
on va inventer la machine à vapeur par
exemple et on va avoir plusieurs gars
qui en vente plusieurs voitures en fait
pas beaucoup de voitures
il explique qu'on est vraiment bas dans
l'échelle du nombre de produits
et comme tout le monde à inventer sa
voiture
on est dans une grande variété ensuite
va apparaître la révolution industrielle
la voiture préconisée par ford et là
tout le monde va avoir la même voiture
or donc peu de variété de produits et on
commence à avoir une voiture pour tout
le monde puisque il ya un peu d'argent
et que tout le monde peut commencer à
s'acheter une voiture ensuite
l'avènement de la production de masse
arrive avec ce qu'on appelle la
wolkswagen la voiture du peuple d'accord
est là et bien tout le monde a la même
voiture et il ya beaucoup de voitures et
ensuite la production et arriver un tout
petit peu en se disant m'écouter oui
c'est bien on veut tous une voiture mais
pas forcément la même
moi j'aimerais bien l'avoir jaune
j'aimerais bien l'avoir rouge ne peut
bien avoir en 3 noir et blanc etc
et donc c'est là on va commencer dans ce
cas passés dans ce qu'on appelle la
production personnalisé et vers quoi on
se dirige
on se dirige en fait vers une production
toujours de masse parce qu'on a tous
besoin de beaucoup de produits mais
totalement personnalisés comment peut-on
imaginer que on va voir des prothèses de
hanche
aujourd'hui les chirurgiens ou encore
4,5 série industrielle de prothèses de
hanche avant de vous la m alors que
trois semaines six mois avant ou trois
mois avant vous avez fait une irm
lavoyer l'irm
ça veut dire que tout le monde est à
même de savoir quelle est la prothèse de
hanche qu'il vous faut voilà donc demain
certainement que cette prothèse de
hanche on vous la fera pour exactement
pour vous donc ça c'est la première
phase le contexte
la deuxième phase est aussi importante
c'est comment vivre technologie
l'usinage tout le monde connaît la
fonderie la forge on est un pays n'est
pas un pays ici dans la loire de
forgeron et de fondeurs pour ça on
connaît on est dans ce qu'on appelle
dans le plateau de productivité
donc une technologie comment elle vit l
on est dans ce qu'on appelle en direct
de l'innovation c'est à dire que tout le
monde s'y intéresse avis on y va on
essaye la recherche à fond donc on
arrive au à ce qu'on appelle le pic des
attentes extrême tout le monde y croit
et on y croit tellement qu on est déçu
donc on va tomber dans ce creux et
ensuite comme c'était une vraie bonne
technologie et que c'est finalement il y
avait du bon derrière
eh bien ça va reprendre sa place et ça
va devenir mature et industriels donc
c'est ça la vie d'une technologie alors
l'impression 3d où elle se situe
aujourd'hui et je vais arriver là dans
la partie où je vais vous montrer
qu'elle vaut un pack et qu'elle va vous
impactés en fait il existe trois
typologies d'impression 3d aujourd'hui
disponible la première c'est celle qui
se passe dans l'entreprise
je vais vous donner quelques exemples
pour vous montrer que aujourd'hui on
utilise l'impression 3d sur des pièces
que vous utilisez tous les jours sans le
savoir la deuxième technologie
d'impression 3d aujourd'hui disponible
c'est l'impression 3d personnel je vais
vous expliquer aussi quelques détails et
la dernière qu'on regardera et hyper
prometteuse mais qui est sa naissance
c'est l'impression de 3d bio alors
allons-y la fabrication additive au
service de l'industrie alors comment ça
fonctionne on va partir d'une pièce qui
a été conçu sur un ordinateur ou même
alors qui aura été scannés avec un
scanner qui aura été même photographié
avec en prenant trois photos aujourd'hui
avec son téléphone portable
on est capable sur internet d'avoir des
logiciels ils vont nous reconstruire une
vision 3d de la pièce donc on va partir
de cette de cette image numérique
on va la couper en tranches plein de
petites branches on va envoyer ça un
ordinateur à une machine outil
on va utiliser en matériaux on va
utiliser une source d'énergie ou notre
technologie qui va permettre de joindre
les matériaux les uns aux autres
et on va reconstruire la tranche de la
pièce que j'avais séparé et en
construisant les tranches les unes sur
les autres
je vais être capable de reconstruire la
pièce que j'avais imaginé les avantages
de cette technologie c'est que plutôt
que d'usiné de partir d'un cube et
d'enlever de la matière je vais utiliser
seulement la matière qu'il faut donc
c'est beaucoup plus d'écologie
d'accord tout la poudre qui était dans
ce bac n'a pas été utilisé par fondu je
vais pouvoir la réutiliser donc
économies de matière alors il ya plein
d'autres avantages et des inconvénients
j'ai pas le temps de parler mais pour
vous donner une idée de là où on peut
passer
et puis après vous voyez cette pièce là
elle a été fabriqué un an coût ce qui
veut dire que je peux me donner une
liberté totale de conception et amener
des fonctionnalités alors c'est quoi une
liberté totale de conception je vous
donne juste une petite vidéo pour vous
expliquer comment on conçoit une pièce
en mécanique dans l'industrie voilà
cette pièce là épiquement si on faisait
un croquis dans les bureaux d'études
d'ingénieur eh bien on va partir donc de
matière parce que on l'a conçu pour être
vinet on voit les pièces les faces
tranché bien droite les angles
perpendiculaire ça veut dire que le
concepteur s'est dit je vais partir d'un
cube et là je vais l'usiné or
aujourd'hui il existe des outils de
conception
ils vont me permettre de concevoir
autrement et là où on va gagner c'est
que la génération à la mienne mais celle
de mes enfants celle de ceux qui vont
arriver sont des jeunes qui pensent 3d
alors je sais bien que notre collègue a
même pas les tablettes mais le jour easy
auront droit à l'âge où ils vivront de
droit et qui commenceront à avoir tous
ces jeux vidéo 3d etc
ils vont développer une approche
conceptuelle il n'est pas celle de nos
générations est en fait si je partais
dans le cube voit là où aujourd'hui je
pourrais arriver
vous voyez j'ai allégé ma pièce et elle
est totalement différente et cette pièce
là j'ai plus qu'à passer en calcul faire
du calcul par éléments finis des choses
un petit peu d'ingénieurs est là où on
se fait plaisir et je vais être capable
oui bah oui il faut bien travailler on
passe du temps donc il faut se faire
plaisir et je vais être capable en fait
de pouvoir ramener cette pièce là avoir
gagné du poids par exemple et dans un
satellite gagner du poids c'est de
l'argent dans un avion aussi et je vais
pouvoir réaliser cette pièce là et la
façon de la réaliser ne peut se faire
que par impression 3d alors je vais vous
passez une série de pièces pour vous
expliquer voilà par exemple en
aéronautique
oh pardon hein aéronautique
voilà une pièce de départ voilà
aujourd'hui une pièce reconçu est
fabriqué à l'impression 3d voilà aussi
une autre pièce où on va gagner en fait
d assemblage vous savez qu'une pièce
assemblée soudé et bien elle a une
chance de rupture elle a une chance de
casser en fonctionnement si je la
fabrique en une fois sans faire de
soudure j'ai beaucoup plus de chance
elles tiennent et qu'elle soit durable
dans le temps alors l'impression 3d là
on a parlé d' aéronautique etc
mais l'impression 3d vous voyez c'est
aussi le bâtiment il n'a pas construit
une maison ou un pavillon en envoyant
trois mois de gros oeuvre à regarder au
robot il arrive alors bon bien sûr on
rêve là pour vous faire réagir mais
c'est ça le bâtiment de demain sera fait
avec des machines qui viendront des
robots qui nous fabriquerons votre gros
oeuvre en quelques jours mais surtout
qu'est-ce qu'on rencontre comme
difficultés dans l'industrie aujourd'hui
que ce soit le btp
ce sont des cahiers des charges qui nous
viennent de designers ou qui nous
viennent et d'architectes et ces braves
gars aient bien ils ont totale liberté
dans la création et nous ingénieur il
nous faut leur répondre nous faut être
capable encore d'imaginer des
fabrications de ce type là avec des
angles des portants
ce qu'on n'est pas capable de réaliser
encore et donc c'est là qu'on va venir
amener tout le bénéfice de l'impression
de 3d alors vous ai parlé de l'industrie
maintenant je vais vous parler de nous
ça qui est important
l impact sur nous la première des choses
le domaine du médical on a tous eu un
plâtre blanc bien plâtre va rappeler
voilà le type de plâtre aujourd'hui
voyez des plâtres pour lequel on fait
une radio on fait un scanner de votre
bras et vous est immobilisé ça ne pèse
pas d'accord et même regarder on peut
mettre même de la pommade
on peut mettre des ultrasons ce qu'on
appelle la fonctionnalité c'est à dire
que sur une seule pièce
on va pouvoir amener plusieurs fonctions
le maintien et les ultrasons by ensuite
deux braves gars là ce qui lui est
arrivé eh bien il a fallu y faire un
implant maxillo-faciale et bien qu'est
ce qu'on va y faire va repartir d'un
scanner on va y faire sa pièce or cette
personne là aussi voilà plutôt que de le
laisser décalotter on va pouvoir leur
ferme et réouvrir quand il ira faire une
chimio ou des choses de ce type là donc
voilà comment ça va nous impacter tous
les jours alors là là ça nous comment ça
nous intéressait le design à la maison
d'accord la bijouterie bijouterie vous
imaginez pour nerfs vous mettez sur son
site la clac clac clac dessiner votre
porte bijoux
d'accord vous êtes designers vous à
votre maison
voilà un avantage ou les des chaussures
d'aller sur un site internet ou créer
votre chaussure
voilà la liberté de conception
et la mode et le luxe alors il ya le
sport quand on monte on colle on
aimerait bien en avoir 2 3 kilos en
moins plusieurs choix soit c'est nous
perdons les 2 3 kg soit on peut essayer
de les faire perdre aux vélos d'accord
faire un vélo en titane plutôt qu'un
acier vers le titane est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus tenaces beaucoup plus
résistant et il pèse moins voilà moto
moto quand on prend deux motos sur sur
les pieds ou quand on s'appelle on peut
faire des architectures regarder ou on
gagne'' vachement de poids alors il ya
plein d'exemples à une raquette de
tennis je vais pas tous les pc
maintenant qu'on a regardé quels impacts
sur nous quel impact à la maison alors
il faut qu'on soit très attentifs et
parce que l'impression 3d à la maison
vous voyez où aller elle est ici c'est à
dire que je vous fais le pari que 80%
des gens qui sont dans cette salle si
vous avez des enfants d'une vingtaine
d'années ou même si vous avez entre 35
et 45 ans vous allez vous dire et ce
serait peut-être le cadeau de l'année
parce que ben voilà ils en ont parlé
il faut que vous soyez très vigilant
parce que c'est effectivement quelque
chose on est dans le pic des attentes
mais il faut pas et vous aurez été
avertis au moins vous dans cette salle
vous risquez d'être énormément déçu bien
que cette technologie prometteuse mais
on peut imaginer quelque chose chez nous
regardez samedi matin je passe ma
tondeuse
page casse le carter aussi je me mets
sur le site web du gars qui m'a vendu la
tondeuse je récupère la pièce veulent en
prime
trente minutes après je continue on
porte plutôt que de la commande etc
c'est là que économiquement ça va
changer le modèle et c'est pour ça que
c'est une technologie d'avenir
d'accord on va plus faire fabriquer en
chine et attendre des mois que ça arrive
non on va reporter la fabrication ici
chez nous et dans est peut-être même
dans nos maisons
or donc c'est là qu'elle impacte
attention à la déception alors des
machines il y en a pléthore des cils de
couleurs des figures des fils avait du
cuivre défilent avec du bois donc vous
pourrez faire des portemanteaux vous
pourrez faire des porte savon et voilà
vous ferez de tous vous essaierez vous
verrez que vos enfants arrêteront la
tablette les coloriages pour dessiner en
3d d'accord il existe désormais des
stylos 3d ou pas pour que les petits
s'amusent et le petit les grands sont
répartis mais ça c'est une des
possibilités également alors maintenant
va arriver là sur les dernières minutes
la fabrication de demain et après-demain
à la bouffe c'est important imaginons ma
fille qui m'appellent alors papa oui
j'arrive je suis à l'aéroport
on n'avait pas prévu d'arriver si tôt
ont bien mangé nous arrive tous très
bien mais sauf qu'elle est à l'aéroport
elles venaient de vacances sur facebook
elle avait mis toutes ses photos de
barcelone par exemple et on se dit
souhaiter ça serait ce serait pas mal si
on y imprimer des pattes parce que comme
c'est à la dernière minute et qu'il faut
le faire vite on ne peut pas faire autre
chose que des pâtes ou pas je vais sur
facebook avec deux trois photos qu'elle
a pris la sagrada familia le new etc
et voilà et en fait on va on va pouvoir
imprimer ce qu'on veut on a fait un
apéritif tout à l'heure on va pouvoir
recevoir des collègues imprimer ce qu'on
veut
comme on veut dans la matière qu'on veut
c'est pas demain matin mais on y arrive
et dans 5 ans 10 ans qu'est ce qu'on va
faire bien on va se trouver dans cette
partie là celle qu'ils y aient
l'impression de 3d bio alors un exemple
de recherche qu'on mène aujourd'hui par
exemple la prothèse de hanche
je vous en ai parlé au début ces
industriels ça existe mais aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit que si on fait des
structures les problématiques qu'on a
entre le métal est l'os c'est la croche
de l'osce sur le métal eh bien on va
pouvoir être capable de créer grâce à
ses technologies des structures la tis
pour que les cellules choisissent de
manière préférentielle de se transformer
en hausse plutôt qu en tissu et donc une
meilleure adhésion entre la prothèse
alors le futur aujourd'hui c'est ce que
vous allez voir là là je vous parle de
peut-être dix ans et qu'une vidéo
démonstratrice il n'ya pas y'a pas
d'impression pour le moment ce n'est
qu'au niveau de la recherche
mais demain j'en suis sûr et vous le
verrez bien en imprimera des organes et
quasiment dessus voilà vous voyez là en
train de coeur d'être imprimé c'est
juste une prospective
mais c'est bien ça sur lequel on va
arriver alors voilà je voulais conclure
par ceux ci je vous aurais fait réagir
est-ce qu'on est arrivé à la malbouffe
est ce qu'on est arrivé pour se sauver
mais je vous ai fait partir de
l'industrie aux domaines du biomédical
et je vous le promets la révolution elle
est en cours merci